it was a busy week for President Trump
and a frenzied week for everyone who
hates him ever since President Trump
took office the left has been totally
obsessed with all things Russia but this
week following the president's meeting
with Vladimir Putin there Russia
hysteria reached all new levels of crazy
watch this did the president share
classified information with Putin did
the president take other steps beyond
those that it took so publicly to
undermine the security of the United
States this president is very happy
making himself a client of Vladimir
Putin who knows what they talked about
behind closed doors in intel language
and parlance and it's the president is
acting like he is the asset for Russia
we are in a 911 national emergency
because our country is under attack
literally there seems to be no rational
explanation for president Trump's
behavior and so millions of Americans
are left wondering if Putin indeed has
something over the president naturally
the mainstream media was even worse take
a look at this this was a blatant
submission to a genuine foe of our
country Vladimir Putin has been invited
to Washington perhaps Donald Trump will
give him the keys to the city or perhaps
more importantly the keys to some ballot
boxes I don't think extreme to use that
that treason words you know adhering to
their enemies giving them aid and
comfort I have no trepidation all about
assigning that treason word we it is no
different that had somebody attack the
United States with missiles it's just as
serious to me as the Cuban Missile
Crisis in terms of an attack or the 9/11
attack the Pearl Harbor attack
Kristallnacht when do we see almost a
shadow government come out and say we
cannot side with the government treason
bribery and high crimes and misdemeanors
treason treason yeah joining us now to
weigh in on all of this absurd rhetoric
is a counselor to the president
Kellyanne Conway
hello Kelli Ann you know as I
listen to that rundown of comments I
couldn't help but think you know treason
is an offense for which you can receive
the death penalty are they looking for
this president to get the death penalty
oh but for a media that is so precise
about the language they always want to
hear from everyone who works here boy do
they just toss words into the salad bowl
and mixes they want to come out with
toxic stew it really makes no sense to
me Janine that they are hunched over and
anger at all times they are
I think physiologically incapable of
finishing a sentence or addressing any
issue without mentioning Donald Trump's
name five or ten times he and I were
looking at the Washington Post the other
day and he pointed out that there were
six of the seven articles in the front
page we're all it were about him and
only because the all-star game was in
town or what probably would have been
seven out of seven and so it tells you
something the obsessive outrage has been
mainstreamed and regularized and I think
this is a very serious point because
it's not just at the outrage and the who
can out crazy the next on cable TV has
been accepted it's now expected you have
a lot of print journalists who have
contracts with these cable news stations
and so even though it has their print
affiliation below their names they're
performing for the cameras and the
viewers on those particular networks I
take complete offense with a smile on my
face but on behalf of those who suffered
loss grievous loss on 9/11 over 3,000
Americans gone
Kristallnacht for 2400 plus Americans
killed at Pearl Harbor my goodness
they're comparing it to this what do the
families feel when they hear that you
know and so it's completely over the top
and I just want to tell you something
else we can't you and I can complain
about it but I have a slightly different
view I'm not sure it really matters I'm
not sure it matters the president's
approval ratings are far higher than the
Democrats in Congress than the
mainstream media's I don't think it
matters because people curate from each
every event what they think is most
important to them what's most important
to them is that this president in the
tradition of the presidents from the
last 75 years beginning with Eisenhower
met with the leader the Kremlin
he's duty-bound to keep us out of war
and he's trying to forge a conversation
on issues that affect both countries and
not the rest of the world North Korea
the Middle East Israel Iran nuclear
proliferation Syria obviously the
Ukraine are so many different issues to
discuss with these different heads of
countries so we've got a president who's
doing his duty which is useiess to keep
us out of war and doing what every
president his son for the last 75 years
which is meet with the leader of the
Kremlin and they're yelling you know the
sky is falling but you know when
Blumenthal says and and it is a 9/11
moment just like before 9/11 what could
they possibly be talking about everyone
is like you know saying what is it that
these people are talking about first of
all it gets somebody like senator
Blumenthal on the next TV to talk more
crazy I have to say he represents the
people of Connecticut Connecticut
suffered losses on 9/11 in the towers
interest if not on those airplanes so
how could he possibly do that and equate
that to the Grievous loss of life the
worst terrorist attack on American soil
in our nation's history let's recap last
week because the media don't want to
talk about it the president started the
week out at NATO where he extracted
forty four billion dollars in
contributions toward the shared offense
from these countries on the way to
securing commitments for hundreds of
billions of dollars more into the future
Secretary Stoltenberg of NATO thanked
President Ronald on Twitter and and in
person you know publicly saying thank
you for doing this it's because of his
leadership and his stewardship that this
is happening that other countries are
keeping their commitments the way that
our country has been he went over to the
UK to reaffirm our great and historic
relationship by meeting with the Queen
who I think reviewed the guards for the
first time we're told in about 70 years
also its resume and then over to his
meeting with Putin which
is not unlike what other presidents have
done with the leader of the Kremlin at
the time I don't want to say one more
thing it is just stark raving mad that
when the media think about Russia
all they think about is election
meddling and really think about the
Supreme Court all they think about is
abortion there are so many different
issues to talk about the president has
said yes he believes the intelligence
Russia interfered but you need it was
unsuccessful interference was no cooling
vision it didn't and rod Rosen science
said that last week when he announced
the indictments of the 12 brush he said
there's no evidence that it affected a
vote or swung the electoral outcome but
it is season the media say that and why
did Obama and Brennan and clapper the
last two who are cable news pundits now
yes why why did they bury the
intelligence that they had they had it
in the fall of 2016
I was the campaign manager the time they
never came to me and said we want you to
see this they buried it because they
thought she would win and Trump would
lose and then all of a sudden it became
a big deal in December in January to him
you know what you know they buried it
because they were part of you know when
they talk about meddling in the election
I think the intelligence community and
the DOJ and the FBI was meddling in the
election anyway Kellyanne conway always
good to get your take on all of this
thank you so much she touched me